Visit ListenLively.com
AINSLEY: WE ARE BACK WITH A FOX
NEWS ALERT, WEEKLY JOBLESS
CLAIMS SOARED TO A
RECORD-BREAKING 6.6 MILLION AS
THE ECONOMY REELS OVER THE
CORONAVIRUS.
STEVE: THAT NUMBER IS MUCH
HIGHER THAN A COMMUNIST HAD
PREDICTED, THEY WERE THINKING
BETWEEN THREE TECH 3 - 5000000 P
LOSING THEIR JOBS AND STRICT
MEASURES TO CONTAIN THE DISEASE
OF CLOSED BUSINESSES AND BROUGHT
THE COUNTRY TO A STANDSTILL AND
MANY PARTS.
BRIAN: THIS NUMBER EQUIPS THE
LAST WEEKS JOB CLAIMS WERE 3.3
FILED FOR ON APPOINTMENT, LET’S
BRING IN SENATOR MARCO RUBIO.
I KNOW YOU WORK EXTREMELY HARD
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT GOES A SMALL
BUSINESS WITH A 2.2 TRILLION.
DOES THIS NUMBER REPRESENT THE
PREVIOUS MOVE BY THE EMPLOYERS
TO GET RID OF THESE EMPLOYEES
AND COULD THEY BE BROUGHT BACK
TO GET SOME OF THE MONEY BROUGHT
ASIDE FOR THEM.
>> IT IS A STUNNING NUMBER IN IT
REPRESENTS THE PEOPLE OF LOST
THEIR JOBS ALL THROUGHOUT LAST
WEEK WHICH IS WHAT WE WERE
WARNING, CAN I SAY SOMETHING
ELSE THAT WAS FRIGHTENING
EVERYBODY OR FREAKING EVERYONE
OUT, THE TRUE NUMBER IS MUCH
HIGHER, WE KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
THERE IS PROBABLY NO STATE IN
THE COUNTRY WHO HAS AN ON
APPOINTMENT SYSTEM THAT IS
PREPARED TO TAKEN THE VAST
VOLUME OF PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING
TO REACH THEM, AND FLORIDA AND
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY THEY ARE
BEING OVERWHELMED, NO SYSTEM IS
SET UP FOR 50000 PEOPLE TO CALL
IN A DAY OR REACH THEM.
THE NUMBER IS PROBABLY MUCH
HIGHER THAN THAT, THE TRUE
NUMBER AND THAT’S WHY THERE’S A
SENSE OF URGENCY TO GET THAT
BILL PASSED AND WHY WE HAVE SUCH
A SENSE OF URGENCY TO GET THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM UP
AND RUNNING.
AINSLEY: SENATOR, WHAT’S YOUR
RECOMMENDATION TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS, I HAVE A FRIEND I WAS
TALKING TO HER AND SHE SAID SHE
WANTED TO PAY HER EMPLOYEES, HOW
DO I GET THAT MONEY, WE’D GONE
TO THE BANKS AND THE BANKS ARE
NOT FAMILIAR WITH WHAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING, SHE’S GONE
TO THE WEBSITE AND STILL HAS
QUESTIONS.
>> THE BANKS SHOULD BE FAMILIAR
BY NOW, I WOULD TELL YOU MY
ADVICE I GIVE EVERY SMALL
BUSINESS, IF YOU HAVE AN
EXISTING BANKING RELATIONSHIP
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LARGER
NATIONAL BANKS BUT IT CAN BE
COMMUNITY BANK AS WELL, REACH
OUT TO THEM IMMEDIATELY, I KNOW
LAST NIGHT ALL THE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT LARGE BANKS AND THE
BRANCHES ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND A GROWING NUMBER OF
COMMUNITY BANKS ARE PREPARING TO
GEAR UP